in other news two big explosions have
gone off near a military hospital in
kabul before rounds of gunfire at least
19 people confirmed dead there's been no
claim of responsibility for the attack
so far faiz zaland is a professor of
political sciences at kabul university
explained earlier to me why these
attacks are difficult to prevent
controlling such kind of events will
seem
far more difficult
in a situation where things are not very
much in order
since the fall of the kabul into the
hands of taliban
there are
a few things missing the very important
thing is that legitimacy recognition
regional cooperation international
communities cooperation
concerns over the
target killing the isis uh
reactivation in big cities
but
taliban should
control uh otherwise
the main
the main thing that people really much
need and want from taliban was
their grip over the security and their
last era if they lose
that grip
if the
insecurity increases i think
it will somehow
discredit taliban's presence in the
power